Speaker 1: I want to play for you an incredible
clip.
This is this is.
I just love this.
This is so good.
There is an activist and student at Dartmouth
College named.
I hope I'm pronouncing his last name correctly.
Jack Koch Mirella.
He went to an event with radical extremist
Republican Congressman Madison Cawthorn, who
continues to claim that Donald Trump actually
won the election in 2020.
And our friend Jack confronted Madison, and
it's a really hero's work.
This was at Dartmouth.
Cawthorn is reduced to a stammering mess,
unable to put together a coherent explanation
to defend his position.
Let's go right to the video.
This is really, really good.
Speaker 3: So I just had a quick question
for you.
Speaker 4: Congressman Cawthorn, a majority
of Republicans believe that President Biden
was not lawfully elected.
Now you know that he was and that he won the
2020 election.
So when will you stop watching your constituents
admit that Donald Trump lost and end this
senseless attack on our democracy?
Speaker 1: So first of all, it's it's a loaded
framing of the question, but for the format,
for what Jack's trying to do, it's absolutely
perfect.
Speaker 4: Well, I want.
You are completely wrong, wholeheartedly disagree
with you.
I believe you on the facts, you disagree with
him on focusing on the facts that President
Biden was lawfully elected.
Absolutely.
Well, let me go to that, right?
There is an unconstitutional logic here.
You propagate the big lies in the discussion.
Would you like to actually go ahead?
OK.
So as you can all see in Article two, section
three of the Constitution, the only people
who have a right to change election law in
the United States of America, all the state
legislatures you saw in six key states, namely
Wisconsin and Arizona, has the worst arbitrators
the state policy, the state governors.
Speaker 1: And now wait, hold on.
Who was it that did the elite legal thing?
That, of course, does not mean that Donald
Trump.
Was it the governors who?
Well, I don't know.
You know?
Yeah.
Well, Trump definitely won autumn elections.
Speaker 4: And who actually will?
Brown will host the state legislature
Speaker 1: when a second.
So was it the will of the people or was it
the will of the state legend who?
What was violated exactly?
Madison changed election laws on their
Speaker 4: own that is unconstitutional.
When you have voter drop boxes that are set
up in parks, when you can give it a signature
verification of voter ID laws that is against
the law's unconscionable, unconstitutional.
Are you against the Constitution?
Are you here when you win the Jan. six insurrection
or are you against the kind of answer to that
when you incited the Jan. six insurrection?
Were you against the common man?
Speaker 1: This kid's got upper management
written all over him.
Jack Coach really, really well done.
And of course, the stuff that Madison Cawthorn
is saying.
We've heard it so many times before, and it's
sort of a Gish gallop when you throw it all
together.
Well, there were it was against the Constitution.
The U.S. Constitution and the states changed
the rules and it wasn't the will of the people,
but it wasn't the will of the legislatures.
But actually, it was the legislatures who
changed.
And when you put a drop box in a park or change
the magic.
Hold on a second.
How does this mean Trump won?
Let's look at these issues one by one by one,
and listen, this Cawthorn, he has his talking
points prepared, right?
He's been he's been perpetrating this lie
and and perpetuating the talking points for
a while now.
So he knows the talking points.
But in a format where you can really take
them one by one and pick them apart, you see
that there's nothing there.
Every single one of these liars should be
questioned and they should be facing exactly
these questions every time they appear in
public.
Explain exactly how it is that Trump won.
Number two, explain exactly how you talk about
the Constitution in terms of the election,
but you never mentioned the anti-constitutional
attempt by the Jan. six rioters to stop the
certification.
Are you for or against that?
Explain it.
It should become impossible for these people
to evade these questions every time they're
in public and a really, really great job there.
By Jack Koch.
Generation Z activist and student at Dartmouth
College.
And my guess is we'll be hearing more from
him.
And hopefully, I mean, at every town hall,
at every opportunity, these people should
be asked these questions.
You've got to be prepared.
You've got to be prepared with rebuttals because
they're going to have some rebuttals, but
really, really nice job.
We're going to take a quick break and we'll
be back after this.